What's the last step of building this cake, Christina.
Okay, my friend, this is the part
that like you have the eye.
I know you're gonna thrive in it.
You already crushed building the cake.
It's decorating the top.
So we make these little sandy things
that we call birthday crumbs.
They're like a short-bready version
of the sponge cake itself.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
And this is where you just let the you of you come to life.
There's no right or wrong way
to decorate the top of a birthday cake.
But you've got birthday crumbs,
you've got birthday sprinkles,
and I've got knives and forks at the ready,
'cause the best part of dessert,
come on, is eating.
Oh yes, this is true.
So I can be interpretive?
You worked hard on this,
my friend.
And be interpretive, go, get it.
Drew, Drew, Drew, Drew, Drew!
Get it, get it, get it!
She's got it!
This is what it's about.
(audience cheering)
Yeah, yeah, go, go!
Sprinkles cure everything.
This is kind of it.
No, of course, we know they don't.
But you wanna know what?
They do something to us.
And that is like the spirit, and the energy,
and the moment that makes us feel good and whole,
and makes us wanna give that goodness and that wholeness,
and give it to anyone and everyone.
And that's the spirit of "Dessert Can Save the World."
I mean, I know it's supposed to go on a, okay--
Well, do you wanna just hold it?
I'm like, "We don't need a plate."
Look at you, but I suppose it's the proper thing to do.
Is that the right thing to do?
Yeah, whatever.
Okay, okay, okay.
It's all going
in the same place.
You wanna know what?
Also, I love to your decor moment
is about just making a little bit of a mess,
which I'm a really big fan of.
Also, I think putting like a nice napkin
and a little plate,
if you're cooking an egg and some spinach for yourself
on a Saturday morning and you're totally by yourself,
they can make such a difference to your mood.
Yes.
But, I mean,
if this doesn't make your mood happy, nothing will.
By the way, here we go.
Cheers.
Oh my god.
Ah!
This is it, right?
This is it!
(audience cheering)
Thank you, Christina Tosi.
Get your copy of "Dessert Can Save the World,"
because it can, and it's in stores now.
Thank you, Christina.
Let's have another magical--
One more, one more.
Magical night.
I just wanna say you crushed it.
You would survive the Milk Bar kitchen.
Look at that, come on!
(audience cheering)
Come on!
(upbeat music)